c'era da quanto tempo siamo qua dentro
si è appena arrivato ma dove siamo
ok ti starai chiedendo che cosa ci
facciamo qua dentro
lascia che ti streghe innanzitutto devo
spiegare le regole del gioco
poi ti racconto come penso di essere
finita qua assegnate questo è un video
interattivo
nello specifico è uno escape room come
puoi vedere ci saranno mai indovinelli
ed enigmi da risolvere ma tu dovrai fare
la scelta finale
alla fine del video fra i quattro scelte
solo una è quella giusta che ti porterà
fuori dalle skyroom e mettere in salvo
siete che quindi mi raccomando the least
al super attento durante tutto il video
perché il video sarà pieno di piccoli
indizi quindi stai attento ogni piccolo
dettaglio e particolari
tieni gli occhi bene aperti io dovrò
cercare di risolvere tutti gli enigmi e
indovinelli non la fine dove dovrei
scegliere tu la soluzione finale
mi raccomando c'è solo una regola non si
fanno spoiler nei commenti non puoi
scrivere nei commenti in qual è la
soluzione giusta altrimenti che gusto
cento gli altri giocatori lo scorso
video interattivo ha raggiunto più di 30
mila mi piace viene compromesso che il
prossimo sarebbe stato un escape room se
questo video raggiunge il 40 mila vi
piace ci sarà un altro video interattivo
e di mi raccomando il lascia un mi piace
e ora ti spiego come credo di essere
finita qua in questa sorta di escape rom
non molto inquietante
allora che cosa stavo facendo sì ora
ricordo ero nella mia cameretta quando
all'improvviso ho sentito uno strano
rumore
pensavo fosse merlino magari qualche
cellino fuori dalla finestra ma poi mi
sono resa conto che era un rumore che
deriva da dentro un armadio
allora ho deciso di alzarmi e andare a
controllare ma mi sono accorta che c'era
qualcosa di strano che usciva fuori
dall'armadio quindi ho deciso di tirarlo
che cos'è esattamente
e niente poi all'improvviso mi sono
ritrovata qua ora che ti ho spiegato
tutto vini entrava nelle skype room e
controlliamo di tipo di oggetto
innanzitutto posto troviamo una cassetta
rossa chiusa un martello una lampada per
una una lavagnetta con un pennarello
ragnatela qua invece questo è molto
interessante
le lettere dell'alfabeto con delle linci
ne ho come l'impressione che questo
indovinello sarà un po complicato da
risolvere ma li abbiamo quadro è un
quadro sembra 3d ma sbaglio cambia
colore guarda vini fin qua è diventato
rosso invece quanti vento più potrebbe
essere un indizio ma ora questo dovrò
fare per primo e se veniamo qualcuno di
questi oggetti ma per gli iniziamo con
quello luminoso
avete visto ha cambiato colore se
dovessi mettere i colori del quadro
rosso e blu
abbiamo già il rosso qua vediamo se
riesco a trovare il blu rosso verde blu
eccolo ce l'ho fatta
e allora cosa dovrei fare forse c'è
qualcosa qua dentro quarti con biglietto
io non riesco a leggerlo però aspetta te
lo faccio vedere turrisi a leggere
qualcosa si capisce niente
guarda sembra che si legga qualcosa ma
ancora non si vede molto bene ho notato
prima che c'è qualcosa di strano da una
sorta di cartolina di plastica ecco si
sono riuscite a toglierla proviamo
posizionare questa cartolina sulla
scritta vediamo ho bisogno di un po di
aria fresca in risalto il primo
indovinello c'è il secondo contando
questo o forse il primo è una pressione
altro indovinello ho bisogno di un po di
aria fresca garantire secondo voi la
finestra
forse provare ad aprire la finestra
proviamo devo togliere questa sorta di
ragnatela da tutta questa ragnatela si
apre non è chiusa quattro foto qualcosa
quarto delle batterie sono tre batterie
wow abbiamo risolto l'altro indovinello
e ora dove dovrò mettere queste batterie
sicuramente non è la cassetta e non nel
martello nemmeno nella lavagnetta quindi
l'unica che si rimane sono queste lucine
ecco qua c'è la cassetta per mettere le
batterie
speriamo che funzionino che non siano
scariche
vediamo ora se funzionano 321 sì
riduzione viva che cosa dovrebbe fare
adesso
forse devo osservare i colori c'è un
codice un codici da decifrare
era proprio sotto le batterie
sembra un po complicato questo codice
proviamo a ragionare assieme e capisco e
propria serve la lavagnetta devo provare
a scrivere la frase o la parola nella
maglietta
nel primo c'è scritto freccia in giù
pallino 18 che gentile precedenti forse
riguarda la seconda riga di lettere
pallino rosso quindi luce rossa se una
luce rossa qua e una luce rossa qua
quindi possano l una qu e che cosa
c'entra il numero 18 però è quasi una
freccia 1 2 3 4 5 11 12 13 14 16 17 18
casi sulla s quasi una lucina rossa che
corrisponde al pallino rosso la freccia
in basso potrebbe essere l'ultima riga
proviamo a scrivere
essere la nostra romagna e vediamo se
poi riusciamo a comporre una parola
vediamo con la seconda parola cosa c'è
scritto seconda lettera 1 dove sarà nota
ma che vuol dire dove sarà andata a b c
manca la cima come un fatto non
accorgermi era dispetto da tutte le luci
e delle lettere che non mi sono accorta
che mancava la c quindi immagino che
dove sarà andata è riferito alla lettera
c quindi dopo la s csc freccia in basso
quindi forse ultimo rita oppure lucino
verso il basso arancione 1 se noi
andiamo verso l'uno abbiamo la c'è la
ragione e la luce verso il basso
quindi penso che sia proprio la sca
numero 4 freccia verso il basso blu 19
il 18 era la s quindi 19 lati c'è la
freccia verso il basso perché la luce
verso il basso e c'è il blu quindi non
violati
penso che siamo sulla giusta strada
mi sembra già di capire che cosa può
essere ma così 5 freccia verso l'alto
arancione 14 3 4 9 10 11 12 13 14 si
corrisponde perché l'uso verso l'alto e
arancione quindi è proprio la o si
capisce che parola è però continuiamo
non si sa mai numero 6 freccia verso
l'alto pallino rosso 11 12
11 l freccia verso l'alto rossa si penso
di aver capito qual è l'ultima lettera
voi avete capito sì dài è facile presso
verso il basso arancione 1 ed è proprio
la canzone verso il basso la parola è
scatola evviva ce l'abbiamo fatta
scatola
quindi ora cosa devo fare non so che
devo aprire la scatola adesso l'unica
scatola che c'è qua dentro
non è proprio una scatola di cartone è
una sorta di scatola degli attrezzi però
è l'unica scatola vogliono ad aprirla
immagino che ora che abbiamo risolto
questo indovinello possiamo aprire le
troveremo qualcosa di utile dentro
vediamo si apre una cosa da sviluppo
forse devo usare la corda per scappare
ma come e poi c'è una pila proviamo ad
accenderla
nei viola mi è venuta in mente una cosa
forse c'è un messaggio nascosto in
questa stanza questa luce viola rivela e
colore ultravioletti quindi proviamo a
illuminare qualsiasi superficie di
questa stanza vediamo se comprare
qualcosa la mente non mi sembra di
vedere niente forse qua la ragnatela
sembra che si illumini ma non penso che
sia un indizio forse qui nelle lettere
c'è qualcosa di nascosto
sembrano geroglifici non capisco vi
ricordate da fare ciò che abbiamo visto
prima
con questa luce si illumina proviamo a
seguire la treccia
vedete questo punto quale si illumina io
penso che sicuramente dobbiamo seguire
la freccia perché se la freccia indica
ci sarà un motivo no no qui non c'è
niente e se provassi a togliere il
quadro non c'è scritto niente
c'è una scritta c'è scritto chiudi il
più di lui
questo che cos'è sembra un nuovo forse
no chiudilo non mi sembra che ci sia
nessun nuovo qua dentro
così quello è comparso adesso
forse si riferisce a questo devos
chiuderlo quindi devo romperlo immagino
qua c'è stato forse mi basta aprire
questo vediamo cosa ci ha detto non
avesse niente e che cos'è un calzino ho
capito poi avete capito e una benda devo
mettere questa per andare nella psy da
un il sottosopra insomma forse si sarà
un indovinello finale o forse la scelta
finale dai venite con me ora metto la
benda e andiamo insieme tenetevi forte
ora funziona
siete arrivati alla scelta finale
ora come ultima scelta
dovrai scegliere uno dei quattro bottoni
con colori diversi o il bottone rosso o
il bottone blu o il bottone verde o il
bottone viola se sceglie il bottone
giusto avrei vinto la challenge e
uscirai dall escape room ma se sceglie
il bottone sbagliato incontrerà il demo
cordone se non te la senti di continuare
o interrompere la strada in gioco hai
sentito devi fare la scelta finale
io non posso aiutarti devi far lato ecco
lì ci sono i quattro colori un pulsante
blu per questa costruzione un pulsante
rosso
un pulsante verde e un pulsante viola
ora tocca a te che sei stato attento
durante tutto il video ti sarà più
facile trovare la soluzione
ora se scegli una di queste quattro case
linee che corrispondono a uno dei
pulsanti mi raccordo fai la scelta
giusta